I don't know if you remember this
because it was really just a very minor
story during the election but there was
this whole email server scandal
involving Hillary Clinton's use of a
private email server uh-oh it turns out
that many Donald Trump staffers have
been using since the inauguration a
private email server this was learned
from a Newsweek report over the last 36
hours or so numerous senior Trump
staffers including Kellyanne Conway
Jared Kushner Sean Spicer Steve Bannon
had active accounts on a Republican
National Committee email system the
system is RN c HQ org if that rings a
bell it's because is the it's the exact
same email system that the George W Bush
administration was using to allegedly
avoid transparency rules after claiming
to have quote lost 22 million emails not
2,200 emails not 22,000 emails not
220,000 emails not 2.2 million emails
but 22 million emails there this is not
a legal right using separate email
accounts at the White House it is not
illegal but it's something for which
Hillary Clinton was eviscerated and
since Newsweek published this story the
RNC has then gone in and deleted the RNC
HQ emails of Bannen Kushner and Conway
Newsweek waiting for further comment the
last time White House staffers used the
same RNC email system Citizens for
responsibility and ethics in Washington
known as crew they were describing it as
a clear attempt to circumvent
transparency cruise director is melanie
sloan and she said in 2007 when the Bush
White House was doing the same thing
that they were using it because quote
they don't want anyone to ever be able
to come back and see what was going on
behind the scenes
these are unfortunate PR optics for
Donald Trump for using this non official
email server and the optics are
particularly bad because of the
hypocrisy of having attacked the exact
same practice by his opponent Hillary
Clinton but the
are actually real cybersecurity problems
here Russian hackers as far as we know
didn't get as much material from the RNC
system as from the DNC system but it was
still a hackable system meaning that
Trump staffers up until yesterday when I
guess these email accounts were deleted
we're using a system that we don't
suspect is hackable that we know is
hackable and of course it's an issue of
transparency because Trump and other
Republicans throughout his presidential
campaign we're talking about were so
concerned about transparency we will be
the party the administration of
transparency Hillary Clinton was not
transparent because she used something
other than the official state email when
she was Secretary of State FBI director
James Comey called her email practices
extremely careless there was an
investigation
it obviously tainted and arguably cost
her the entire election in the end and
here we find out that Trump staffers
were doing the exact same thing we just
don't know whether in the 22 million
lost Bush emails classified materials
were sent over a private email system
because the 22 emails are gone and we
don't know what was sent through this
email system over the last four days or
however many it was five I guess almost
six days at this point before the RNC
deleted those emails it's yet another
example of the non transparency that
we're getting from the Trump
administration but the story goes even
further Donald Trump seems to still be
using his unsecured iPhone you'll
remember that Breitbart very loudly
criticized Hillary Clinton for using a
non secure blackberry in February of
2009 and there's every indication based
on some of the signatures of the the
metadata from the tweets that Trump is
sending even though we know that it's
someone near him usually dictates it to
someone near him that he's using an
unsecured Android phone it's all
projection it's all projection Hilary
used the private email server actually
Trump staffers we're using a private
email server Hilary used an unsecure
blackberry Donald Trump appears to be
using an unsecured Android phone it is
all projection all the way down and mark
my words the trumpets do
not care they didn't care about grabbing
by the [ __ ] they didn't care about
could shoot him on Fifth Avenue and not
have any repercussions they didn't care
about Mexicans they're sent they're not
sending us their best they're sending us
their rapists and criminals although
some I'm sure are good people they
didn't care about ridiculing disabled
reporters disability they're not going
to care about Trump doing the exact same
thing Hillary Clinton did because in the
end it's Trump it's not Hillary Clinton
doing it send me your thoughts on
Twitter at D Pakman